[Música]
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición iremos desde aquí desde el
centro de parís hasta su periferia y
allí tomaremos impulso para ir hasta la
alta saboya en los alpes franceses
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en abril de 2019 el mundo vio atónito
como un incendio consumía parte de la
catedral notó a dama de parís desde
entonces ya comenzaron las obras de
restauración pero aún se sigue
investigando que pudo producir este
incendio por ahora hay pocas
conclusiones pero sí varias pistas
es la única foto del incendio tomada de
cerca bajo la estructura de madera por
un empleado en la catedral a las 18 48
el fuego aún no había consumido el ático
pero ya estaba fuera de control
después de tres años de investigación el
origen de este incendio sigue siendo un
misterio y alimenta toda clase de
hipótesis unas horas después de los
hechos la sospecha se centró en los
trabajadores que instalaron que este
andamio gigante ese día una decena de
ellos se encontraban en la estructura
trabajaban para la reconocida empresa de
andamios europeos apoyas para el jefe de
la empresa no te dan de parís era la más
hermosa de sus obras de construcción y
guarda algunos recuerdos de ella al día
siguiente de la tragedia todos sus
trabajadores fueron interrogados por la
brigada criminal les preguntaron acerca
de unas colillas encontradas en las
terrazas los obreros afirmaron haber
fumado pero siempre en el exterior nunca
en el ático y según julian de brass eso
habría sido imposible
los hombres trabajan con un traje con un
cubre calzado con guantes todo pegado
con cinta tienen su vestimenta de
trabajo tienen un arnés de seguridad sus
cascos sus mascarillas de protección si
alguien hubiese tenido ganas de fumar no
lo habría hecho en el ático técnicamente
es imposible hacerlo
para los investigadores la pista de una
colilla mal apagada es improbable
actualmente la empresa es parte civil
entonces fue un problema eléctrico
en medio del armazón de madera en la
base de la aguja había tres pequeñas
campanas casi inaccesibles
en 2011 por petición del clero se añade
un sistema eléctrico para hacerla sonar
de manera remota esos motores habrían
podido provocar un cortocircuito
según las autoridades religiosas se
respetaron todas las normas se detectan
está muy claro se hizo primero siguiendo
las reglas con el acuerdo del estado e
incluso con la inspección del estado de
orito los policías señalaron que el
incendio no se originó a la altura de
esas campanas pero exploraron la pista
de un problema eléctrico en otro lugar
de la estructura en notre damme había
cableados intrigantes hay una lámpara
halógena puesta sobre una viga unos
cables mal fijados aquí un cable de
extensión colgado sobre una escalera 15
días después del incendio un experto se
preocupó y recomendó en un informe que
se debía llevar a cabo una búsqueda
exhaustiva de cualquier cable suelto
cable de extensión permanente o cable
provisional olvidado en cada campanario
último escenario considerado por los
investigadores una herramienta con
baterías de litio que se habría
recalentado lo suficiente como para
prender fuego el armazón según afirma
este ex en incendios que conocen no
creerán desde hace años live action en
realidad las baterías se pueden
recalentar y desencadenar un incendio
pasa con celulares pasa con distintos
materiales con automóviles así que es
posible que posible las valoraciones
continúan sin ninguna imputación de
momento tan sólo las pistas criminales o
terroristas han sido descartadas por los
investigadores
la magia de disneylandia llegó a parís
hace 30 años y para festejar este
cumpleaños este parque temático organizo
una muy gran fiesta de cumpleaños en la
que participaron miles de fanáticos de
mickey de mini mouse
30 años de fiesta 30 años de alegría y
de magia estos fans de disney no se
habrían perdido por nada del mundo este
aniversario
[Música]
vamos a festejar
desfiles animaciones hoy se espera una
multitud de visitantes en el parque para
esta jornada tan especial
no queríamos perdernos esto venimos
especialmente aquí para el trigésimo
aniversario deberíamos estar trabajando
pero nos tomamos el día justamente para
estar aquí para los 30 años estuvimos
aquí para los 25 años para los 20 años y
para los 15 años para los 30 años era
necesario así que vinimos otra vez
william moyer estuvo aquí para la
inauguración tenía tres años lleva el
castillo tatuado en el brazo y hoy
vuelve con su hija lo tengo grabado en
el corazón me acordaré siempre de lo que
sentí el día de la inauguración
este era el paisaje antes de la apertura
del parque campos de hecho el proyecto
enfrenta una fuerte oposición pero
prevalecieron las promesas de empleo y
de crecimiento económico
[Música]
y estoy de acuerdo con la compañía walt
disney
es un contrato muy muy interesante estoy
seguro de que será un gran éxito y texas
en abril de 1992 por supuesto fue mickey
quien abrió las puertas de este nuevo
parque de diversiones con más de 9 mil
millones de euros invertidos desde su
creación disneylandia parís se convirtió
en el primer destino turístico del
continente actualmente el parque emplea
16.000 trabajadores en 30 años 375
millones de visitantes han disfrutado de
las atracciones constantemente renovadas
[Música]
un éxito comercial que se ampliará a
partir de este verano con la apertura de
nuevos espacios
ver gorriones que vienen a comerse las
migas de pan y de croissant que habían
quedado en los platos en las terrazas de
los restaurantes eso es una imagen del
pasado porque la población de estas aves
ha disminuido en un 75% en los últimos
20 años aquí en la capital sin embargo
la alcaldía ha lanzado un programa
piloto para hacer que los pájaros
regresen buenos días buenos días señor
esta habitante del distrito 18 de parís
recogió hace unos días en la alcaldía
una casa para pájaros gratuita durante
la primavera la protección de las aves
es una apuesta para este encargado de la
ecología urbana es lo que decíamos antes
que el piso octavo era un poco alto pero
al mismo tiempo como es una colina los
gorriones pueden volar así en horizontal
esta casa para pájaros está lista para
acoger tres copetones y esta parisina
multiplica las atenciones para sus
futuros residentes una especie que ella
espera a ver regresar pone hebras de
cabello y de lana a su disposición para
construir nidos cómodos
en 2006 cuando llegue habían gorriones
les daba de comer y venían regularmente
y luego fueron desapareciendo poco a
poco para que estas aves regresen parís
pone a prueba un programa instalando
casas para pájaros en tres barrios
parisinos que fueron seleccionados con
la liga de protección de las aves la
situación es preocupante en 15 años la
población de gorriones disminuyó en un
75% en la ciudad las razón es una
urbanización más intensa y la refacción
de las fachadas
al renovar los edificios desaparecen las
cavidades y las fisuras así que no hay
posibilidad de hacer nido allí entonces
significa que los gorriones no tienen ni
alimento ni donde anidar y
se han instalado 52 casa nidos en
escuelas y residencias particulares para
que las aves vuelvan a sentirse como en
casa
además parís trabaja en una gestión más
natural de los espacios verdes por
ejemplo este prado no será cortado antes
del final del verano de esta manera las
plantas tendrán tiempo de germinar dando
grano a los pájaros y flores a los
insectos esto permite explicar al
público urbano que la biodiversidad no
se trata solamente de los osos polares
muriendo en la antártica sino que
también es algo que ocurre en la puerta
de la casa y que sobre todo se puede
actuarse
si la experiencia llega a tener éxito el
programa podría extenderse a todos los
distritos de parís además si se consigue
que nazcan nuevos gorriones en la
capital aquí se quedarán de por vida
pues el gorrión es un ave sedentaria
la alta saboya es conocida por halagar
clet por la fondo pero en medio de esas
montañas también hay un plato ancestral
conocido como lipton ya un grupo de
personas amantes de este tipo de recetas
volvió a prepararla en hornos
tradicionales y para que no caiga en el
olvido la quieren inscribir en la unesco
un puñado de aficionados renueva una
receta de antaño le pone un platillo de
sal o de dulce para deleitarse con los
restos de la masa para pan una generosa
capa de puré cebolla y puerros
conjugados con las especialidades de la
región el queso de montaña el jamón y el
ajo silvestre
estamos en plena cosecha del ajo
silvestre así puedo personalizar le
poniendo polvo ese era mi pequeño aporte
porque estoy aprendiendo
es el legado de nuestros ancestros y
claro me alegra mucho de participar de
imaginar una receta antigua al gusto de
hoy y no el sexo me hiciste
la cocción es rápida le pone no necesita
más de 5 a 10 minutos en este horno para
pan que acaba de ser renovado y
encendido por primera vez en 20 años
estas son las primeras impresiones de
este panadero que se puso manos a la
obra para que este pedazo de historia no
cayera en el olvido
esto es como nuestra tarjeta de
identidad además esto era un plato de
pobres no era un plato de ricos esto es
propio del campo de los campesinos uno
le ponía no se le ponen tantas cosas
encima pero era todo eso todo un éxito
una bella dupla cierto por lo
repetiremos algunos quisieran proteger
este sabroso patrimonio de la región
para esto se plantean enviar una
candidatura a la unesco
el man de los chorizos es quizás uno de
los colombianos más conocidos de la
capital él fabrica y vende sus productos
por toda la ciudad pero además a través
de sus redes sociales da a conocer las
historias de sus clientes en su mayoría
latinoamericanos
reportaje de diana buitrago en una
cocina subterránea de parís juan david
castillo fabrica chorizos colombianos
este manizaleño dejó su vida de abogado
y gastó los ahorros para emigrar a la
capital francesa por su emprendimiento
llamado el mando los chorizos este
colombiano ha encontrado éxito en los
paladares franceses yo tome el este
producto como una bandera para poder
vender mi propia cultura entonces eso es
como una excusa para hablar de colombia
a bordo de su moto el man de los
chorizos recorre las calles parisinas
además de sus productos lo que ha hecho
de su emprendimiento un éxito son las
numerosas historias migratorias de sus
clientes una vez entrega el pedido les
toma fotos y comparte sus vivencias a
través de sus redes sociales el objetivo
es que los latinoamericanos se sientan
menos solos en el proceso migratorio
será que
sus redes sociales han sido un impulso
para muchos latinoamericanos que llegan
a francia en busca de una mejor vida
considero que es un compromiso muy
grande el tema de que la gente me busque
hoy en día como para trabajo y para
tener oportunidades en este país
cuando david castillo se ha convertido
en un referente para la comunidad
latinoamericana en francia
me alegro mucho porque yo sé yo sé lo
que es empezar y por eso
para asumir el alto número de
solicitudes de empleo y alojó en parís
castillo abrí una asociación para
facilitar la integración de los
migrantes latinoamericanos en la
sociedad francesa
hasta aquí esta edición de francia en
foco gracias por habernos acompañado
continúen con nuestra programación en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]